hello and welcome to the show this week
two stories about leadership and what it
takes to get a country behind you this
is Beth Rigby interviews
who should be Scotland's next leader all
three contenders have suffered a
bruising start to the contest
[Music]
fast Minister Alex salmond who described
the contest as the Titanic heading for
an iceberg at full speed
[Music]
plus what is it about Gareth Southgate
that helped change the fortunes of the
England football team
the playwright James Graham tells me why
he's putting Southgate on the stage with
a story that explores the themes of
identity race and revolution
[Music]
the shock resignation of Nicholas
stargen just over two weeks ago dealt a
huge blow to the Scottish independence
movement so who should be the one to
pick up the pieces and lead the SMP all
three contenders have seen their
campaigns thrown into controversy at
some point so much so that the former
leader and fast Minister Alex salmond
has compared the contest to the Titanic
so does he think the eventual winner is
doomed to fail and what would that mean
for the dream he strived towards for
decades
Alex Sam thanks so much for joining us
on the show today at such an important
time in Scottish politics and I I want
to start off with Nicholas sturgeon's
surprise resignation as SMP leader and
also first Minister last month for many
years you were the closest of allies and
together you built this formidable
electoral machine in the SMP now's your
chance to pay tribute to her
well I mean as I've said I mean Nicholas
uh both as an election winner and as a
communicator it's one of the most
formidable politicians that has been
over there over the last while and both
of these attributes were amply
demonstrated through her career and what
will her Legacy be that's more difficult
to be because I mean obviously an SMP
politician or a Scottish independence
politician uh you know you have to look
for the Legacy as how close you advance
towards that goal the and there and I
think Nicholas
you'd have to say that you know Scotland
is not any closer to Independence than
it was in 2014 certainly the dial hasn't
shifted greatly elections have been won
in the interim but the the deal in
Independence hasn't been shifted now
that's a of course a hard criteria to to
judge politicians you know it's bigger
because most politics I'm a UK
politician would largely be judged by
how many elections to do it but I think
uh somebody who believes in Scottish
independence as I do unequate those they
would want to be judged by how close you
advance towards that that goal or that
dream so you you clearly didn't agree on
her her strategy but her leaving
um Scottish politics in this way at this
in terms of the leadership at least I
mean it's the end of an era isn't it of
of you and and then her and I know that
you didn't really like each other by the
end but is there any sadness do you look
back in sadness now about how the
relationship ended well well of course
but I mean you know that note that
that's something between nickel and
myself but the important point for the
you know the other five and a half
million Scots and particularly the
supporters of Independence is a a
combination which was taken Scotland
looked like an exitable march to
Independence there's no very much a up
in the up in the air just two more
things on this
um do you think that Nicholas Sergeant
exiting in the way she's exit with no
obvious successor has let the calls down
she's made things extremely difficult
for her successors in the sense that
they've been plunging that they're
depend now they may swim you know not
not everybody gets flung in the deep end
sinks and they're talented individuals
but they've got a very short period of
time I'd like to talk to you about the
candles but I do Peter Morrell SMP chief
executive given what you've just said do
you think he should stay in post well no
I don't but I mean I'm not really the
personal task it's the the candidates
the next leader because of the way in
which this has been handled you mean
well Peter obviously uh you know I
didn't think Peter should stay in post
back in 2014 I think it's one of the
reasons why you know Peter is uh hasn't
held me in any regards a sentence
because I didn't think it was an
appropriate combination to have the the
leader of a party and the country or
simultaneously and I mean as well at
least one of the candidates on perhaps
two of them have said in this contest it
wouldn't be be it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be decided as reasonable in any
business organization and there's
question marks all that now this
particular question marks you know so I
don't think so but you know that's not
really for me and that's you know that's
for the SMP and the SMP candidate let's
move on to the leadership let's talk
about Kate she had a Kate Forbes had a
tough start over those remarks around
gay marriage you're a Christian does it
concern you that her ideas about gay
marriage and sex outside marriage seem
to have essentially disqualified her
from the chance of becoming Legion and
fast Minister oh I I don't think she's
disqualified and but she's had a rough
start I don't think well let's continue
the theme position is irredeemable but
and and you know I think
it would be of great concern not just to
me but if people's religious convictions
or lack of convictions uh disqualified
them from a leadership position in a
political party on the other hand the
Kate has I've seen from a more recent
pronouncements it has got to explain
better the very reasonable distinction
you make between a private faith and
public policy and now that that
distinction has been made hopefully
people are more comfortable about it you
know you know well one of the difference
I introduced equal marriage and we did
it before any other country in these
islands and when we did it back in 2011
2012 it was quite controversial I want
to ask you about Hamza Yousaf uh and
he's now the favorite when he took
advantage of forbes's troubles and
criticized her positional gay marriage
now as he was saying you you were the
first Minister legislating for same-sex
marriage back in 2014 when Mr Youssef
was in your cabinet he voted for equal
marriage initially but he later missed a
crucial vote on that legislation did he
or anyone on his behalf ever get in
touch with you as first Minister back in
2014 to discuss that final vote Yes
can you expand on that well therefore I
mean I've been very reluctant to get
involved with this because you know it's
an internal SMP leadership battle and
you know I really don't have a dog in
this race you know and and everything I
see you know people say oh he's only
saying that because he's leading
developer you know but you were the
first minister at the time so you all
know yes so what happened well I mean my
memory is that I was contacted 10 days
or so before the before the vote but the
vote was known and uh and told that
Hamza was arranging a ministerial
appointment
I've discussed it with people who are
with me at the time so I know it's well
their memory is the same as mine but
what was the reason that was given to to
have to skip the vote well and I didn't
discuss the the thing landfill was the
Assumption was there was pressure
there's a lot of religions but a lot of
religions were were canvassing and
opting there's no secret though there
was uh there was that but it was a free
phone people could do it like I
administers
who were against a equal marriage and
who voted against equal marriage and
they continued as Minister sorry you you
but you're saying that there was
pressure Mr Yousaf was on on depression
that was communication lots lots of
people directly all through a third
party that was communicating but lots of
pressure from the Muslim Community
no doubt other communities as well I
mean look that aspect of it to me is
irrelevant it was a conscience for a
free vote Hamza had made his General
views on the issue perfectly clear and
the first reading quote and it was
totally uncontroversial it was a
conscious vote a conscience vote but can
I just this is what he's I'm just going
to play because this is what his
explanation was if I may can we this is
I've told you what that business was
you've asked me quite rightly earlier
this week but what was that business it
was a Scott who was on death row for
blasphemy in Pakistan that we were
desperately trying to get released a
series of meetings needed with Pakistani
government and Pakistan no other day in
your diary no other point in your diary
you couldn't have rearranged that to
make such a historic vote in the
Scottish Parliament again I made the
historic vote in stage one where are you
under pressure though by religious
groups at that point let's just clear
that up what representations were made
to you from religious groups because the
timing from your opponent's point of
view looks very suspect look a couple of
things first of all I think every single
member of the Scottish Parliament was
lobbied by not just Faith groups there
was a number of other groups who opposed
equal marriage at the time I was no
different but I also speak to my
community in the Muslim Community in
particular I speak to them very often
about the positions that I take some
will agree some will disagree but to
think that the Muslim Community has one
homogenous view I think would be
incorrect
so I just want to clarify this because
it matters about the leadership contest
I think it doesn't did he miss the vote
because of
religious pressure and he didn't want to
know
a meeting
no no you asked me what my memory was
was I contacted to say that Hamza had
arranged a governmental meeting a on the
day of the vote and that was sometime
before the vote the answer is yes I
remember that
but you know there's memory you know may
be different from my let's put it that
way
what do you mean well you know he he
seems to he seems to have a different
recollection from what I do or what Alec
Neil has so be it so just to be clear
your recollection was that it was a
conscience vote
um but that vote was missed because of
religious pressure that it was a vote
that Mr Yusuf perhaps wanted to avoid
well that's your recollection well
that's my recollection Okay the reason
I'm asking you is because
Mr Yousaf has used Kate Forbes position
on gay marriage to criticize her yeah
and then there's a point about whether
or not he for religious reasons I always
tried to dodge that vote and that
matters
my observation is he did that once with
it and he shouldn't have done that in my
view but uh you know most of the the
stuff that's been aimed at Kate was you
know the various I don't know what you
call them accolades or whoever it was
from behind the scenes and incidentally
for all the candidates all three
candidates it would be a tremendous idea
and this is the last piece of advice I'm
going to give to this I'll be leadership
election call off that sort of stuff it
doesn't look good and in terms of
um
you and the SMP in your future do you
rule out ever joining or rejoining is
that is that chapter in your
Independence Journey now closed
rejoining the SMP would you do you
completely rule it out well I mean it's
unwise to ever rule anything out in
politics but the my focus on I believe
I've been if they've heard the palace
all my life uh and uh for the vast
majority of that I pursued it through
the through the SMP I hold the s p an
enormous affection but you know I lead a
political party Aleppo which I think is
a a substantial role to play have you
had any contact with Ash Reagan since
Nicholas sturgeon's departure I mean
I've uh I mean I'm not going to talk
about the conversations I've had but if
you let's talk about three candidates
I've been out as I've already explained
to you for reasons I know Hamza well
because he used to work for me about
nothing else and uh you know I've I know
the the two women less well uh well
into the booth but I'm not going to tell
you when and I wish all three candidates
well in the context let me just ask you
about the couple more things the
coronation Stone the stone of Destiny or
coronation Stone was returned to
Scotland in 1996 and now it's needed to
go back to England for King Charles's
coronation but you don't think that it
should be allowed to go do you well it's
not my most serious policy that I'm
putting forward at Beth but you know in
a context where the legitimate desire of
people in Scotland to at least have a
referendum on self-determination has
been denied by the Westminster
government I don't really see why any
Scottish government should just meekly
say we'll give you back the property
which you stole 700 years ago so would
you watch whoever wins this contest
whoever becomes first minister to refuse
to allow that stone to go back I
probably would actually but they're the
better but so probably a whip it away
before the contest is finalized that's
the sort of Bin that was the kind of
underhand trick that was stolen in the
first place Alexander I've got one more
question for you Independence once
seemed within touching distance you
managed to secure
that Independence referendum at the
moment it looks like it's a more distant
dream do you still think it will come in
your lifetime yes it will and as someone
said the dream shall never die
okay Alex Simon thank you so much for
your time be a pleasure thank you
after my interview we asked for a
response from Hamza Yusuf to those
claims made by Alex salmond about why he
missed a crucial vote on same-sex
marriage he had a different version of
events to the former fast Minister my
recollection is very different to Alex
Hammond's recollection Alex Hammond is
also I think by any objective measure
um he has he has of course backed other
candidates in this race if he has every
right to do that Minister for
parliamentary business who would have
been in charge four slips for any
Minister has made it very clear Joe
Fitzpatrick that I was not one of those
who raised concerns around the equal
management I've given you a full account
corner of the reasons why I had to miss
that vote if it had taken place if I'd
been there I would voted for it the vote
took place today is Alex Hammond not
telling the truth to you then well as I
said my recollection is different next
the award-winning writer James Graham
he's famous for his works on stage and
screen and in his new upcoming work dear
England turns his Focus to football it's
set for release this summer and it tells
the story of how Gareth Southgate
revived The Fortunes of the national
team it explores themes of identity
masculinity and racism as well as the
public backlash the team suffered when
taking on political and social issues
James thanks for coming on the show and
let's start with the big news this week
about your new play about Gareth
Southgate and what you call the gentle
Revolution he's been leading what's the
revolution you're talking about and why
did you want to turn that into a drama
I just love any any National Institution
or any system that at the time of its
greatest stress someone comes in and
disrupts it and changes it and they
either succeed or they fail and I think
if you think back it was like a long
time ago because of the success of what
Gareth has done if you go back all the
way to 2016 it's like England was at the
absolute lowest ebb and then he goes on
this huge Journey where he wasn't just
talking about performance and results
I I think he was talking about something
much much bigger about spirit and soul
and character and identity what is it to
be a young English man in the 21st
century what is it to be English and and
the name of the play D England is based
on this open letter that he wrote in
2021 to to not just England fans but to
the nation and it was a really political
letter wasn't it was that the
inspiration for you that wasn't the
inspiration I've been thinking about
this for a few years almost ever since
and I don't want to reduce his mission
down to this but
if we remember England had never won a
penalty shootout in the World Cup before
we were like one of the worst in the
world at penalties at our own game that
we invented and no one could figure out
why and obviously Gareth himself has a
personal memory of what it is to miss a
penalty and then he broke that curse in
Russia in 2018 for the first time and I
think that was symptomatic of something
bigger going on culturally in the
English game he's quite political would
you say I don't know this I mean I think
he's on he's not afraid of the idea that
football can be more than just sport or
that a football player can be more than
just an athlete that they can represent
something they can be a role model and
when you look at anything from Marcus
rashford to what Raheem Sterling and
people have been doing finding a voice
and inserting themselves into politics
he's not afraid of that but to me my
growing understanding of Gareth is that
his Vibe is really he's an introvert
anyway and it's quite internal and what
he's trying to draw out of his players
is something bigger and if that's if
you're World experiences is you've
experienced racism then why can't the
game own that why can't you talk about
that if that's your life so he's yeah
he's yeah the most prominent expression
of southgate's Revolution if you like
quite was was the team taking the knee
before games and it became this woke
political statement the minds of some
people and Lee Anderson now deputy
uh chair of the conservative party was
so incensed by this that he said he was
not going to watch the games and you
might sort of disagree with that James
but does do you accept that he speaks
for a lot of England the Lee Anson
doesn't that Southgate doesn't
well he's my mp Lee Anderson from from
Ashfield and I I watched that happening
um I don't want to dismiss it because
like you said maybe there is a part of
the country that feels the same I think
it's interesting that he he was often
criticizing
the players for performative version
signaling and I equally think you could
accuse Lee Anderson of doing the same
that was quite a performative bit of
populist politicking he did just on sort
of
southgate's view though the racism that
Spilled Out after rashford Sacramento
missed those penalties in the euros and
they they did sort of dis reflectively
like a disconnect between southgate's
modern take on the game and how he saw
it and the reality of perhaps how
some of the fans did and the sort of
sickening attitudes of some of the fans
yeah we all remember that and it was
incredibly upsetting and disgusting and
I guess
a lot of that stuff we felt had been
have been buried some of those ghosts
and but they're always sort of there and
president and and I think what I find
um comforting and inspiring about that
moment though is how those basically
young Lads still those young men
took a breath took a moment and
collectively responded with such Grace
and such articulation and such decency I
think that is symptomatic of what is
going on in that team
the history of England often has been
one of these men not quite surviving
some of the incredible pressures that
are put on their shoulders the way they
articulated it was just really beautiful
we've written so many uh plays and
screenplays you're arguably Britain's
most celebrated political playwright and
screenwriter and did you set out when
you were at Asheville comprehensive
school to be who you have now become oh
my God no it's a big comprehensive
school and a poor area but for whatever
reason my Drama teacher decided that
working-class kids should do theater and
not have any stigma to it and and I just
fell in love I fell in love with
entertaining and storytelling and that's
why it was the genuine privilege of my
life to be able to do Sherwood last year
which was a story set in a red wall town
I think the red wall often is like a
it's like a black hole like a lot of
light and energy goes into it but very
little comes out of it do you think that
we focus sufficiently on class and do
you think we should be talking about
class more than we do we don't remotely
know how to talk about class
particularly in the Arts I think and I
think because we're squeamish about it
because we don't quite know how to
define it I get squeamish about it
talking about it now because I think am
I a fraud because I I know I Come From A
working class background but now I'm a
playwright with plays in the West End
and my income has changed from what my
parents was am I now no longer working
class therefore can you not have a
working class playwright and I think the
problem of definition is is part of it
um but you're right like even like bafta
has been a really incredible and really
brilliant
um in recent years about having a real
focus on underrepresented groups and
making sure the people that voters are
really aware of that they have my
sympathy with the fact that one of the
only metrics that they don't know how to
measure yet is class so it's not
mentioned when people vote for a film or
vote for a TV drama but bafta came into
a bit of criticism didn't it in the
because there was lots of diversity in
terms of the nominations but actually
what came out was I don't think any
ethnic diversity in terms of winners
right it was disgraceful it was 100
white winners and that is not
representative of the countries that are
making the art and I think I think I I
slightly feel about it I think I think
they would have been
confused and disappointed without
speaking on their behalf because they
have put real effort and systems in
place to make sure that underrepresented
stories get get more recognition but
there's still a human element that you
can't control and I imagine they're
gonna have to think about that talking
about should I want to talk as opposed
to their your hit TV series crime drama
I'm sure lots of people be excited to
know that the second series is coming
back well the second run like the first
be based on real life events it will be
inspired by things that have happened
yes so so the first series took
um it was inspired by some some killings
that took place in my Village a few days
down from where I lived and they even
though they were remotely politically
motivated
because of the the tensions and the
politics of a town ripped apart by the
miners strike 30 years previously people
projected onto it politics that weren't
there and it reopened Those Old Wounds
and I was living in the community at the
time and I really remember how upsetting
it was to see them that police return to
the community the same police force that
had tormented this town and and
exacerbated those divisions people were
really upset by that the season two's
come at a time when
industrial action with strikes in
schools and transport networks the NHS
and Beyond are so prevalent in our
national Consciousness will those
subjects feature in your next yeah
series I think so yeah well it was so
strange because obviously TV dramas take
a very long time to write and then
produce so I began the first series of
Sherwood about three years ago and I
couldn't believe actually that what
emerged during the production in the
broadcast about the last great National
strike was was this industrial action
which we've not seen on a scale since
obviously something is in the in The
Ether or the Zeitgeist and similarly I
think in particular
leveling up and Regional inequality and
and the lack of investment in the East
Midlands in particular uh will be a
political firework in the in the show
and in particular
um I can't believe this has happened but
obviously in relation to the real life
reopening opening of a brand new mine in
Cumbria one of the story points in show
world 2 will be a consultation about
reopening a pit in Nottinghamshire and
whether that's what the community wants
or is that just holding on to a Heritage
that's passed
so so it's going to feature the
reopening of a mind so it kind of ties
it implies the past to the present
exactly I think well I think what was
really um I was really grateful for that
there were a lot of the the affection
for the first series seemed to be not
about the crime drama element it was
essentially a story about community and
how painful it is when a political
choice is inserted into a community and
divides it and the minor strike was
basically pre-remain leave in terms of
splitting families and splitting friends
and I still find it very upsetting it's
still the case that people will cross
the street from someone who made a
different political choice or families
brothers and sisters can't speak to each
other because they were forced to make
this choice you have become a chronicler
if you like the red wall
um and it's a theme that as you say has
taken on huge political significant sort
of driven by Boris Johnson and red wall
and leveling up
and around brexit and about brexit being
this conduit in which there was an
argument that forgotten communities
thought this was a way of taking back
control to use the parlance of of Boris
Johnson do you feel that the community
you came from that these communities are
represented accurately in our political
discourse
no not at all and that's why I think
drama comes in because the tendency I
think in political discourse of course
is to imagining these communities as one
single homogenous block of uniform
opinion and in Ashfield there are you
know there's remain voters and leave
voters there are Working Class People
middle class people probably upper class
people that I've never met them
um there were liberals and there are
social conservatives and people are
complicated and contradictory and fluid
actually looking at the future of the
red wall do you think that political
events like partygate the cost of living
crisis the current strikes over public
set to pay do you think it will change
opinion again in seats like Ashfield
where Lee Anderson is now representing
your community definitely it definitely
cut through when I when I spend a lot of
time there
um now gloriously back with my family
and friends because of Sherwood and it
being said in that community and there's
no question in my mind that certainly
partagate cut through and
the feeling of Injustice that people
made sacrifices that it was it's
perceived that
um the people in power didn't so
something is changing and shifting I've
got no idea whether it will uniformly go
back to um to labor do you think Lee
Anderson is too ideological then for the
people of Ashfield because he doesn't
seem like a pragmatist to me I mean he
would definitely have his have his fans
but I also know people are people don't
necessarily enjoy
um the stirring I guess they would call
it someone who is who is who is um
deliberately trying to disrupt uh
something and there's um there's you
know my communities and places like them
there's a resistance to I think
show-offs people call them uh and
there'd be a sense of some people would
think he needs to wind his neck in a bit
and focus more on on policy rather on
these culture wars and Lee would
disagree and he would go look I'm trying
to represent the viewpoints of my town
all I would say to Lee is there is not a
uniform consistent view that comes from
these places and you can never claim to
fully and completely represent them
because you'll only ever be representing
one yeah it will go labor again next
collection then I genuinely don't know
but I think according to all the polling
it's going to be incredibly close so I
hope you'll be there in Ashford on the
election I'd love to be there with you
well I and I'm looking forward to
watching uh your next play and your next
series of shows so thank you James for
seeing us today
James Gomez talked about two of my
favorite subjects politics and football
well I hope you enjoyed this week's
conversations if you scan this QR code
on screen now you can watch all of our
interviews online and all the previous
episodes of the show
and if you scan the QR code on screen
right now you can listen to the Beth
Rigby interviews podcast that's on the
Sky News app or wherever you get your
podcasts
well that's all for today's show thank
you so much for watching and thank you
to my guest Alex salmond and James
Graham
[Music]